gpt4 is the latest AI system from open
AI in 2019 Microsoft began its 10
billion dollar investment in artificial
intelligence startup open AI the cash
and computing power it offered help give
rise to chat GPT the most powerful
language AI the world has ever seen for
Microsoft the bet is AI will redefine
people's relationship with computers we
now have machines that are so fluent in
human language every place that you
interact with the machine
ought to be much more fluent in human
natural language and I think we'll start
to see that change coming in a lot of
different places as well and it'll just
really redefine the interfaces that
we're used to the way that you're used
to talking to a machine
the chat gbt is so good at imitating
humans the red flags have shot up even
open AI admits the risks
my worst fears are that we cause
significant we the field the technology
the industry caused significant harm to
the world this led to calls to pause or
at least slow down deployment of AI are
you going to continue to invest in
larger more powerful more highly trained
language models I think the potential
for this technology to really Drive
human productivity to drive you know GDP
across the globe to bring you know
economic growth across the globe is just
so powerful that we'd be foolish to set
that aside do you feel you're playing
with fire as you develop and expand
these models those concerns seem pretty
far away from what we're actually
working on in the technology that we're
working on as Microsoft sees it much of
the concern is based on misunderstanding
the world loves a disaster movie and
there have been several put out with AI
playing a large dominant role in it and
so people are quick to sort of jump to
oh we've we've entered the realm of This
Disaster Movie with without really
understanding the capabilities of this
technology people talk about the AI
takes over but it doesn't have the
capability to take over these are models
that produce text as output so we want
to make sure that we work with
Regulators to say here are the really
potential benefits and let's make sure
we're leaning into those and making that
possible but we definitely think there's
a place for a regulation in this
industry Microsoft has stiff competition
Google is World leading in its AI
research it doesn't look like big Tech
is slowing down in its race for AI
Supremacy so society and our Regulators
have to speed up thinking on what the
safe AI looks like